[Musique]
la météo sujet numéro une conversation
est aussi parfois source de confusion
certaines notions nous échappe des
lacunes qui ne sont pas sans
conséquences pensez par exemple aux
fameuses indice de refroidissement
éolien
on n'aurait pas pu choisir une meilleure
amie on parlait de refroidissement
éolien
parlons-en mais bien craquer leurs
particules ont d'abord c'est quoi le
refroidissement mais c'est comme évident
le en ce moment il fait froid
ouais il fait beau mais il ya du vent
parfois 10 maioni c'était une
combinaison entre le vent et la
température donc ça va être un indice
qu'on va donner sans lui m d'unités
alors par exemple - 10 aujourd'hui un
vent de 20 à 25 30 kilomètres à l'heure
ça va donner un refroidissement éolien
de -15 -18 tout mais on s'arrête là on
dit pas moins 18 degrés on ne parle pas
d'une température un refroidissement
éolien c'est pas mesuré la température
c'est facile on a un thermomètre on voit
ça descend jusqu'à -10 c'est comme ça
refroidissement éolien c'est plus une
sensation sur une peau nue pour une peau
propre audace ou ton manteau mais
vraiment sur tes joues mais est ce qu'il
ya un consensus sur le fait que c'est
viable c'est fiable dans ce sens que ça
a été étudié en laboratoire ok il ya des
gens il ya des volontaires qui se sont
vêtus appropriées de façon appropriée
pour des températures froides dans un
laboratoire et dans ce laboratoire là on
a joué avec les températures mais on a
aussi par exemple garder une température
constante mais ajouter des grands
ventilateurs avec des ventes de
différentes forces et il est prouvé que
sur la peau on ressent beaucoup plus
froid pourquoi c'est comme ça c'est que
là le corps dégagent une espèce de
couche protectrice qui réchaud qui garde
le corps assez chaud mais quand le vent
souffle la couche protectrice alors le
corps qu'est ce qu'ils doivent faire il
doit la recréer et si ça se fait de
façon répétitive comme ça mais à un
moment donné le corps lui est en train
de perdre son énergie
alors à partir de 2001 on a dit comment
on pourrait rendre accessible aux gens
alors cindy une sensation tout le monde
sait ce qu'est une sensation donc on va
le faire comme ça et les 10 il n'est pas
parfait
est ce que d'autres modèles vers
lesquels on peut tendre qui peuvent
rendre compte davantage
réalité ben je sais qu'il ya des études
qui se faisait il ya quelques années le
but serait de trouver un indice
universel de de confort thermique en
fait et c'est un d'ici là pourrait
remplacer autant le facteur de
refroidissement éolien univers que
l'humidex qui est semblable aussi l'été
qui pourraient être utilisés en tous
lieux en toute température à tout moment
de l'année et qui tiendrait compte et la
température bien sûr et du vent et
l'humidité et de l'ensoleillement donc
ça serait ça le paradis d'avoir un
indice qui serait simple aussi à
comprendre mais pour le moment on
fonctionne avec l'humidex l'été et avec
ce sera avec grand plaisir que je
parlais du budget avec toi faut juste
pas oublié je m'en tienne encore parce
que c'est vraiment important
le refroidissement éolien c'est pas me
durable c'est une sensation donc on ne
lui met pas des degrés celsius au bout
de lady ce n'est pas faire injure